[Musica]
[Applauso]
avete mai provato a oltrepassare e
saltare un'asticella nel salto in alto
in uno stadio di atletica segreto per
riuscirci corsa veloce spingo e
oltrepasso
e a tuffarvi da 10 metri in un
trampolino i tuffatori dicono che è una
sensazione davvero spiacevole
quell'impatto con l'acqua è fisico è
spiacevole fisicamente ma anche la
sensazione di vuoto durante il volo
Eppure dicono che quella sensazione è
straordinariamente spiacevole
vivo in Finlandia da 15 anni e i
finlandesi anche hanno creato qualcosa
di straordinario L'invenzione
dell'avantosauna una sauna a 80 gradi
centigradi la fanno in inverno e fuori
ci sono meno 20 gradi centigradi escono
e si tuffano in un buco ricavato dal
mare ghiacciato vi chiederete l'ho mai
fatto Sì un paio di minuti in 15 anni e
ho provato una sensazione
straordinaria Quelle fuori dal normale
la paura
cosa facciamo e cosa scegliamo di fare
di solito a domande o a commenti tipo
non farei mai quella cosa è una pazzia
No no questo non fa per me conosciamo
bene le azioni limite quelle che ci
fanno paura le azioni estreme ma
conosciamo e riconosciamo le emozioni
ero un ingegnere
impegno massimo sette giorni su 7 avevo
proseguito una carriera accademica e mi
trovavo in team avvincenti competitivi
internazionali sembrava andasse tutto
bene
eppure c'era qualcosa che non funzionava
Era come se fossi inutile inutile A me e
inutile a tutti
era una sorta di intelligenza invisibile
non riuscivo ad usare la mia
intelligenza mi mancava
l'intelligenza emotiva
l'intelligenza emotiva è uno strumento
che ci permette di capire i nostri stati
emozionali quelli propri quelli che
ognuno ha tutti diversi ma ci permette
anche di capire gli Stati emozionali
degli altri e così facendo Creiamo un
processo empatico con gli altri
intelligenza emotiva ci permette anche
di risolvere problemi di decidere
problemi e anche di affrontarli nel
cosiddetto modo giusto
con un team di professionisti o
analizzato nello specifico la relazione
che intercorre fra emozioni e azioni
ovvero cosa proviamo e cosa facciamo e
soprattutto se questa relazione soddisfa
i nostri desideri oppure i nostri piani
futuri I nostri obiettivi
primo risultato Ovvio siamo tutti
diversi
Chi prova qualcosa e chi Prova
qualcos'altro Chi agisce in un modo e
che in un altro ma il secondo risultato
è stato avvincente ovvero non c'è
relazione e allineamento fra le nostre
emozioni e le nostre azioni ovvero non
facciamo ciò che proviamo e ancor meno
ci dimentichiamo dei nostri desideri
in un forum mondiale di economia hanno
deciso infatti di regolare quei
comportamenti che permettessero ai
grandi leader di essere perfetti e
quindi di avere quelle azioni perfette e
hanno stilato un modello noto come il
modello cognitivo comportamentale
azioni chiare precise azioni regolate in
modo che un leader e un leader di
successo ma quanto questa efficienza e
perfezione funziona
un'altra ricerca che ho condotto è stata
proprio analizzare quanto questa
perfezione influisse sulla produttività
dell'azienda di solito in aziende
tocchiamo argomenti come la fiducia
nell'azienda la fiducia con i colleghi
la fiducia in se stessi nel posto di
lavoro ma anche per esempio la crescita
personale dentro la nostra vita
lavorativa ho trattato anche un elemento
come il coinvolgimento quanto ci
sentiamo dentro un'azienda oppure la
nostra autonomia quanto possiamo dare i
nostri liberi pensieri all'interno di
un'azienda tutto sotto un'unica finalità
vedere quel cambiamento positivo che ci
permettesse di dire sì la produttività
vuol dire
perfezione vuol dire stilare dei
comportamenti Giusti in una prima fase
ero riuscita nel mio obiettivo Infatti
se siamo produttivi Siamo positivi ma in
una seconda fase c'era un declino di
dati perché le azioni diventavano azioni
dovere azioni da fare e questo non
permetteva alla nostra intelligenza
emotiva di emergere Perché in fondo
l'intelligenza emotiva È curiosità
scoperta non avere doveri esplorazione
sappiamo bene cosa fare
Ovvero le azioni sono concrete sono
tangibili
sappiamo valutare quanto fare ma
sappiamo valutare come fare
se abbiamo azioni meno meno meno meno
meno cioè facciamo meno facciamo poco
anche le emozioni diventano imparalisi
non vengono stimolate
al contrario se facciamo tanto più più
più più più più più più più più più più
più
le nostre emozioni si allontanano c'è un
distaccamento siamo presi soltanto dalla
parte attiva di noi stessi e non dalla
parte emozionale
quando abbiamo imprevisti situazioni
magari troppo difficili da affrontare il
nostro sapere come fare Viene Di solito
dalle esperienze passate e quindi
riproduciamo sempre le stesse azioni
facciamo e rifacciamo sempre nello
stesso modo ma in realtà creiamo una
gabbia una gabbia logico adattativa
ovvero ripetiamo sempre la stessa cosa
in contesti completamente imprevedibili
non controllabili
oppure Siamo in un labirinto siamo già
entrati nella labirinto ci muoviamo nel
labirinto Ma non sappiamo scegliere non
sappiamo prendere la direzione e non
sappiamo uscirne
le scelte in realtà appaiono soltanto
regolate da tre elementi molto semplici
chiamati elementi primordiali delle
scelte si basano su le esperienze
passate so cosa fare oggi perché l'ho
fatto già da emozioni ho provato già
queste emozioni con questa azione e
quindi le conosco e poi da azione agisco
su cosa fare perché già l'ho fatto prima
nella realtà non è così la nostra vita
reale è davvero complessa infatti sono
state classificate circa 200 emozioni e
categorizzata in 27 categorie emozionali
a fronte di queste emozioni ci sono
potenzialmente mille azioni che possiamo
fare in un solo giorno e quindi come
facciamo a capire a Quale emozione
combinare quell'azione
emozioni e azioni per etimologia sono
movimento
emozioni da qualcosa e azioni verso
qualcosa allora agire fare andare verso
oltrepassare
ma sono le emozioni che decidono quali
azioni fare o sono le azioni che
decidono quali emozioni fare e quindi
sono le azioni che causano le emozioni o
le emozioni che causano azioni
c'è una teoria detta del non sincronismo
del sincronismo non perfetto o della
totale casualità ovvero avvengono
emozioni a caso e azioni a caso non sono
assolutamente relazionabili
nella mia vita professionale Ho
visualizzato gli stati emozionali
connessi alle azioni non legati alla
casualità ma avere consapevolezza di
emozioni influisce sui nostri stati
emozionali sul capirli e soprattutto
capire i nostri valori quei principi
base che ci danno linfa vitale e la
paura la paura è un'ottima alleata
perché ci dà limiti nei nostri istinti
ma anche curiosità perché possiamo
riadattarci e ritrovarci in situazioni
diverse solo grazie alla curiosità e
possiamo sperimentare nuove emozioni
solo grazie alla curiosità
anche esplorare noi stessi Quante
attitudini abbiamo quali risorse abbiamo
ci sono molte risorse innate dentro di
noi
infine il divertimento perché gli stati
emozionali sono complessi sono davvero
pesanti e col divertimento riusciamo ad
alleggerirli e a chiarificarli Ho
visualizzato questo flusso di stati
emozionali come una Ninfea La Ninfea
sono le azioni visibili quelle
bellissime ne basta una per essere
visualizzata e La Ninfea ha delle radici
le radici sono le nostre emozioni che
fluiscono e ci permettono di cambiare
Se volessimo davvero cambiare
focalizziamoci sulle emozioni negative
perché le emozioni negative ci danno la
direzione su cosa non fare
le emozioni negative sono le emozioni
allarme che ci permettono di fare azioni
positive
Siamo noi che decidiamo come rimodellare
quel confine tra provare e fare Può
essere un confine invalicabile Come
possiamo decidere di dissolverlo
completamente
vorrei lasciarvi con un'immagine Questo
è il Golden Bridge e si trova in Vietnam
e un ponte molto lungo tortuoso
Altissimo viene sorretto da una mano
pensiamo che questa mano sono le nostre
emozioni ci sorreggono in ogni minuto
nella transizione
nell'oltrepassare nell'andare verso
nuove transizioni nuove situazioni
ascoltiamo le nostre emozioni e
rendiamole meno casuali
un ascolto attivo delle nostre emozioni
ci permette di rimodellare rivedere la
realtà con una percezione diversa e
quella stessa realtà ci evoca stati
emozionali completamente diversi
e poi curiamo le emozioni Per fare ciò
che vogliamo e per essere chi siamo
[Applauso]
[Musica]